[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'union européenne annonce ne pas
reconnaître les résultats des dernières
élections en biélorussie et prévient des
sanctions contre des personnalités du
pays seront prises
onze jours après le scrutin contesté
d'alexandre loukachenko pour un sixième
mandat les tensions restent vives sur
place avec un troisième manifestant tué
l'union africaine l'union européenne et
les etats unis condamnent le coup d'état
omani cette nuit le président ibrahim
boubacar kéita annoncé sa démission
après avoir été arrêté par des
militaires en révolte il affirme pouvoir
mettre une place cent trente neuf en
place par dans une transition politique
civile
et appelle ce soir les populations à
reprendre leurs activités et l'arrêt du
vandalisme
en france purge ans face au communisme
avec 2238 nouveaux cas de contamination
ces dernières 24 heures la question du
port du masque obligatoire suscite le
débat et divise les français à cela
incertitude à quelques jours de la
rentrée scolaire avec la crise sanitaire
la crise économique des suppressions
massives d'emplois sont prévues
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt francs
si vous nous rejoignez l'union
européenne rejette donc les résultats de
l'élection présidentielle en biélorussie
après une réunion de ses 27 états
membres lui a avancé des sanctions
contre les dirigeants biélorusses
responsable selon elle de la répression
une prise de position contestée par
alexandre loukachenko les détails avec
robin pu l
le ton monte entre l'union européenne et
alexandre loukachenko les 27 membres se
sont réunis par visioconférence ce
mercredi pour discuter de la situation
en biélorussie depuis l'élection
contestée d'alexandre loukachenko
le pays est le théâtre de manifestations
violemment réprimées par les forces de
l'ordre
une violence que condamnent l'union
européenne ces 27 dirigeants promettent
des sanctions aujourd'hui nous faisons
passer trois messages clairs tout
d'abord nous soutenons le peuple de
biélorussie qui réclament la liberté
fondamentale est la démocratie
deuxièmement nous sanctionnerons tous
les responsables des violences de la
répression de la falsification des
résultats de l'élection le peuple de
biélorussie et descendez dans la rue
pacifiquement et les autorités ont
répondu avec violence c'est inacceptable
en réponse au sommet européen alexandre
loukachenko a convoqué un conseil de
sécurité exceptionnelles le président
biélorusse accuse notamment les
occidentaux de financer le mouvement de
contestation
alexandre loukachenko suggère aux
puissants européenne de se concentrer
sur leurs affaires internes
je leur donnerai un conseil simple avant
de nous pointer du doigt inscrivez à
l'ordre du jour de leur réunion les
questions liées aux manifestations des
gilet jaune en france
côté bleu émeutes aux états unis je
voudrais qu'ils examinent d'abord les
manifestations contre
confinement instauré à cause du corona
virus en allemagne et dans d'autres pays
européens
il ne faut pas aujourd'hui pointé du
doigt la biélorussie pour détourner
l'attention des problèmes qui existent
en france aux états unis en allemagne et
c'est un bras de fer diplomatique suivi
de très près par le kremlin vladimir
poutine s'est entretenu ce mardi avec
angela merkel emmanuel macron il a
alerté la chancelière allemande et le
président français sur les risques
d'ingérences de la part de l'union
européenne
une mise en garde réitérées par le
ministre des affaires étrangères sergueï
lavrov
ce que nous entendons actuellement en
provenance des capitales européennes
principalement des pays baltes lituanie
estonie ainsi que de pologne et du
parlement européen ne concerne pas
lukashenko les droits de l'homme et la
démocratie
c'est une histoire de géopolitique
uniquement et cela concerne également
les règles que nos partenaires
occidentaux veulent introduire dans la
vie quotidienne sur notre continent et
dans d'autres parties du monde
face à la pression internationale
alexandre loukachenko a demandé à son
gouvernement de rétablir la paix dans
les rues de minsk et de renforcer la
sécurité aux frontières
mais la mobilisation ne faiblit pas de
nouvelles manifestations ont eu lieu ce
mercredi pour dénoncer la fraude
électorale
d'autres biélorusse préfère de leur côté
organisé des rassemblements l'an soutien
au président alexandre loukachenko et
pour claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales la réaction de
l'europe s'adapte au contexte encore
incertain en biélorussie cette réaction
était prévisible
elle est d'ailleurs relativement
relativement prudente parce que la
situation est assez difficile à saisir
et elle est très
lüthi ve à minsk et en biélorussie en
général le plus important c'est que le
conseil européen a réaffirmé que c'était
de la population de l'est la russie de
trouver les voies et moyens conduisant
une solution politique
l'union européenne a pris également de
mesures concrètes qui consiste à
réorienter vers la société civile les
flux dead qui existe entre l'union
européenne et la biélorussie et puis
deuxièmement de préparer une liste de
personnalités qui sont liées aux fraudes
électorales ou qui sont liées à la
violence de la répression
et ces personnalités sur l'objet donc de
sanctions ciblées probablement
interdiction de détenir des comptes en
banque les uns et à possibilité
d'obtenir des visas le mali secouée par
un nouveau coup d'état les militaires
ont pris le pouvoir cette nuit face à
cette situation le président ibrahim
boubacar kéita a démissionné également
annoncé la dissolution du parlement et
du gouvernement il dirigeait le pays
depuis 2013 la junte appel ce soir les
populations à reprendre leurs activités
et l'arrêt du vandalisme
ils demandent une transition politique
civile et promettent des élections
un des militaires au pouvoir s'est
exprimée affirmant qu'aucune victime
n'avait été déplorée parmi la population
lors du renversement du président
le comité insiste que lors de ses
activités
on a déploré jérôme ans contrairement à
certaines allégations qui parle de
quatre morts et dix blessés
le comité insiste car notre niveau on
déplore zéro mort et zéro blessés
vive le comité national pour le salut
qui peuvent vivre le ps ouvre l'ère
démocratique
vive le mali je vous remercie près de
son côté l'onu convoque une réunion
d'urgence l'union européenne et les
etats unis ont condamné ce coup d'état
l'union africaine a pour sa part exclu
du mali de son organisation et réclame
la libération du président et du premier
ministre un le conseil paix et sécurité
de l'union africaine suspens le mali de
l'union africaine jusqu'au retour de
l'ordre constitutionnel et demande la
libération du président boubacar kéita
du premier ministre et des autres
responsables du gouvernement arrêtés par
la force par l'armée
1 depuis plusieurs mois une coalition de
l'opposition réclamé le départ du bk et
de son gouvernement la population
malienne reste néanmoins partagé je vous
propose d'écouter quelques réactions
c'est pas cela qui a fait pour l'état
c'est le peuple malien qui a fait couler
tant ses qui a déclenché tout ça mais
c'est le chaos total
le pays n'a comme vous le voyez il est
un nouveau c'était le chaos total dont
le peuple a crié qui on a demandé à
l'ex-chef d'état il embarque était
d'écouter son peuple il n'a pas voulu
dans l'armée c'est assumé et puis c'est
tout moi je vois pas le problème
hier à ma grande surprise les présents a
été déposé déposé par des militaires
vraiment magique condamne le coup d'état
parce que ça n'avance pas un pays ça
nous met toujours en retard
les militaires et qui y viennent nous
promet beaucoup de choses mais rien ne
s'est passé est réellement dans les
normes
et pour en parler nous sommes avec bray
maëly dicko sociologue enseignant
chercheur à l'université des lettres et
sciences humaines de bamako bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france alors tout d'abord cet appel ce
soir d'agente à reprendre ses activités
l'appel à la population et arrêtées le
vandalisme en gros c'est circulez ya
rien à voir
alors on peut effectivement du facteur
météo a fallu leur volonté d'assurer la
continuité de l'état parce que cet après
midi ils ont provoqué tous les
secrétaires généraux des ministères pour
faire une réunion envie de voir comment
l'état peut continuer à fonctionner
normalement
à partir du moment où le prêt dans les
deux cas a rendu la démission et qu'il a
dit ou la table et et le gouvernement
ça veut dire que la possibilité aux
militaires et discuter avec les forces
vives de la nation l'opposition la
majorité et la paix civile
donc pour moi sa famille simplement une
volonté des militaires des parents le
mali ne soient pas floutés
pourquoi vu de l'extérieur on peut se
poser cette question pourquoi le
président kate a accepté aussi vite de
partir de démissionner alors que
finalement il a été élu démocratiquement
vous savez il y avait une branche
spéciale le mali 1 tu pouvais depuis
pratiquement trois mois maintenant et
les mouvements est resté dix
tremblements et est parvenu à mobiliser
des milliers de maliens à l'intérieur de
bamako mais aussi à l'intérieur des gens
en france et aux états unis
le mouvement est parvenu par paralyser
l'économie malienne parce que la
politique est désormais réglée pour
n'abrite aussi avec quelques camions il
pouvait s'appeler mais en raison des
activités de m5 ces camions qui avait
arrêté de circuler il y avait une grève
les enseignants y avait recommencé
malgré les promesses du paysage et des
cadres d'appliquer les salaires les
syndicats des polices projet c'est de
partir jeudi en grève de même que le
syndicat des postiers des affaires
étrangères et la semaine prochaine
c'étaient les civils je voulais partir
en grève le blocage en allemagne avait
serait favorable
les militaires n'ont fait que mettre fin
à une sorte d un pays qui est resté sans
gouvernement plus de deux mois donc là
c'est un fait indéniable aujourd'hui
l'armée souhaite en appel une transition
politique civile est ce que vous y
croyez vous à cette transition politique
civile alors j'y croise savez il ya des
cités il ya des signaux qui font
qu'aujourd'hui les militaires n'ont pas
le choix d'assurer cette transition
steve hill c'est d'abord les civils qui
sont descendus dans la rue pour dénoncer
la mauvaise gouvernance la demande la
santé de l'éducation de la sécurité et
qui ont dénoncé la corruption et les
militaires eux mêmes leurs qu'ils ont
fait le coup d'état
le communiqué qu'ils ont lu à la
télévision
ils ont récupéré ils ont repris
exactement les clients donc de la rue et
c'est pour ça que ils n'ont pas un mot
c'est quelqu'un qui sait simplement
comme une image et ce manhwa gay et ils
ont annoncé que le gourma serait dirigée
par
un civil que la france est intéressant
parce qu'ils ont pris la mesure de même
elle est malien 120 millions les
militaires ils sont 8 milles environ
donc ils savent que la pression ils
n'ont pas le choix de finir les communs
parce que sinon eux mêmes balles et moi
oui alors les militaires qui promettent
d'ailleurs un scrutin présidentiel
prochain des élections prochaines
est-ce que selon vous ça vous paraît
possible à court terme alors à court
terme non parce que vous savez il ya un
contact et au niveau du fichier
électoral début 2018 la cedeao elle même
à l'issue des élections présidentielles
2018 avait recommandé de réviser ses
fichiers électroniques faisait l'objet
d'un contentieux ensuite il faut aller
voir les corps électoral malien aller
vers des personnels c'est une demande
l'ensemble de la classe politique ont
fait de l'ex-majorité présidentielle
après il y as besoin de réviser la
constitution
ces besoins a été évoquée par la maille
l'extrême représentent-elles par
l'opposition et là c'est steve hill tout
le monde était d'accord qu'il faut
initier des réformes et ensuite même la
question de l'agencé sociale des
élections parce que malia plusieurs
structures sous des électeurs ce qui
fait que finalement on entend toujours
les mêmes problèmes têtu 92 et c'est
d'abord une mise en confiance de la
société civile mais aussi des mouvements
et respect mais aussi de l'ex majorité
et vous savez il faut faire des
tractations pour que les militaires ont
aussi attaqué des civils qui ne pas
participer à une gouvernance et les sens
il ne traîne pas de casseroles sauver
des ja c'est steve hill en soit c'était
un parcours de combattant et après ça il
faut savoir bien sûr les personnes qui
vont composer le parlement de transition
est aussi l'organe détention et sa
presse où ça qu'il faut mettre en place
un comité qui va attaquer des familles
donc c'est pour dire que à mon avis ça
prendrait une année et demi deux ans au
pouvoir par des élections générales
crédibles parfum et il va convenir à
tout le monde sans compter que les
les autres pays d'afrique de l'ouest en
tout cas cedeao à eux ne sont pas du
tout d'accord ils ont condamné ce coup
d'état comme d'ailleurs les états unis
et l'union européenne la cedeao qui
multiplie ses sanctions vers le mali il
ya une marge de manoeuvre pour pour ces
éléments pour ces états et ses groupes
d'intervenir sur ce qui se passe au mali
actuellement
vous savez la cedeao a tenté des médias
quand ils ont tout essayé ils n'ont pas
pu rapprocher les deux camps notamment
les intérêts les plus délicats parce que
à un moment donné en allemagne les
militaires ont fait on peut appeler ça
ils savent que les coups de pouce pour
créer un cadre de dialogue entre maliens
et les condamne à ses habituels des
nations unies de la cedeao vont passer
les convois ça c'est habituel mais il
appartient aux maliens de se faire
confiance pour relever les défis et je
pense que tous les acteurs en conscience
de cela
y compris la mort de présenter leur pib
qui est encore au pouvoir
reconnaissez il y avait besoin
d'améliorer la gouvernance et sa
gouvernance et faire travailler qu'avec
un pouvoir un physique qui est dirigé
par des hommes aussi crédible qui ne
traîne pas de casseroles nombre de
réformes
en fait si les maliens s'entendent entre
eux la vidéo sera obligée d'accompagner
le processus parce que le mali à cette
première nous avons l'état islamique
grand sahara ici nous avons le groupe
plus petit et à l'islam et aux musulmans
et si on laissait le mali contre le mali
comme ça les pays voisins qui vont
sombrer et demain donc à mon avis et
coordination des politiques macro mais
ils n'ont pas le choix de la compagnie
les mali gouvernement avec une dernière
petite question rapidement emmanuel
macron le président français vient de
s'exprimer
à l'instant sur le mali il avait déjà
condamné ce coup d'état il dit que la
lutte contre le terrorisme et la défense
de la démocratie sont indissociables une
réaction sur cette déclaration du
président français français avait salué
pour avoir présenté pour sauver donc
vous savez l'on descend des discours
c'est là le fait que la nage et et au
mali il ya un besoin d'établir efforts
tarifaires du n'était plus possible avec
le président bk et il ya aujourd'hui
renversement de ce régime
le portier pour les maliens de refonder
leur gouvernement pour aller voir henri
iv e république
ce qui serait bien c'est que la france
et l'union européenne ne se faire un max
de saper les fondations de la
gouvernance concertée du politiquement
correct et pour aider les maliens dans
le cadre de l'accord politique inclusive
à restaurer l'autorité de l'état et pour
pouvoir accompagner tous les efforts de
barkan la mairie cement mali dans
l'intérêt du mali la sous région et du
monde
merci beaucoup il y est dit qu je
rappelle que vous êtes sociologue
enseignant chercheur à l'université des
lettres et sciences humaines de ben
commercial vous devant était avec nous
la france continue de venir en aide aux
libanais après la double explosion à
beyrouth le 4 août dernier
au total ce sont près de 400 militaires
français spécialistes dans les travaux
et dans l'humanitaire qui se sont rendus
sur place le colonel de ligue 2 ni de la
barre a voulu rappeler les liens et la
mythique unissent les deux pays
nos derniers éléments nous ont rejoints
avec le bâtiment calao la frette et qui
arrivés dans le port
il y a deux jours et nous avons récupéré
l'ensemble de nos capacités
au total nous comptons près de 400
militaires spécialistes dans les travaux
et l'assistance humanitaire et nous
avons emmené avec nous environ 150
véhicules de travaux et des camions pour
travailler en étroite collaboration avec
les forces armées libanaises
on ne pouvait pas rester insensible à ce
qui arrivait à la population libanaise
en particulier nous les français qui
regardons toujours vers cette partie du
monde avec qui on se sent un lien
particulier
et quand il s'est agi et que le
président de la république a voulu a
voulu apporter une aide significative
la question s'est pas posé pour nous il
fallait il fallait venir il fallait
proposer notre aide
il fallait voir quelconque où on pouvait
apporter et travailler en étroite
collaboration avec les fans qui
connaissent très bien le pays et qui
peuvent orienter notre intervention
en france la lutte contre le commis 19
qui continuent de circuler activement
2238 nouveaux cas de contamination ces
dernières 24 heures un collectif de
médecins milite pour le port du masque
obligatoire dans tous les espaces clos
ce sera chose faite en entreprise y
compris en open space dès septembre mais
le collectif ces 19 a saisi le conseil
d'état il veut étendre à tous les lieux
fermés
en avril déjà il avait saisi la cour de
justice de la république contre olivier
véran alors ministre de la santé
concernant le manque de protection des
soignants avocat du collectif fabriès
division est et sur d'autres antennes
écoutez si on a choisi sans
considération de la distanciation social
de masquer tout le monde dans les
entreprises c'est parce qu'on a
considéré que le virus pouvait s'y
propager et qu'à ce titre il fallait
protéger tout le monde
pourquoi est ce que cette mesure ne
serait pas applicable ailleurs à quel
titre
en fait où le virus circule et il faut
protéger tout le monde de façon
identique ou le virus ne circule pas et
alors il faut arrêter de masquer il faut
arrêter cette mascarade précisément mais
nous nous considérons aujourd'hui les
médecins disent il ya une reprise de
l'épidémie
cette reprise de l'épidémie peut être
stoppée par des mesures cohérentes et
par des mesures qui finalement vise à
protéger tout le monde de façon
identique
arrêtons les exceptions arrêtons les
mesures différenciée qui par ailleurs
effectivement d'une conséquences
redoutables c'est que plus personne n'y
comprend rien et avec la crise sanitaire
le nombre de violences a augmenté dans
les structures médicales c'est ce que
révèle un rapport du comité
international de la croix rouge
les agressions ont atteint un niveau
inquiétant les détails en images
e
[Musique]
à quelques jours de la rentrée scolaire
le protocole sanitaire adoptée par
l'éducation nationale début juillet n'a
pas changé avec le rebond du nombre de
cas de contamination
les enseignants s'inquiètent un syndicat
demande au gouvernement de décaler la
rentrée scolaire d'une semaine pour
préparer un retour plus serein du côté
des parents d'élèves la fcpe déplore un
manque d'information et de préparation
de la part de l'éducation nationale à
moins de quinze jours de la rentrée
scolaire
nous n'avons toujours pas d'information
sur l'évolution du protocole sanitaire
une fois de plus nous mettons les
familles et les enfants dans une
situation de l'angoissant de questions
sans réponse et en fait on recommence
comme on a pu vivre ce qu'on a déjà vécu
à partir de mai lorsque le chemin de
l'école était possible il faut organiser
aussi la classe autrement en petit
effectif donc par groupe pour permettre
justement parce que le virus se propage
loin ensuite bien sûr il fallait
enclencher des travaux assez conséquent
sur l'ensemble des sanitaires au niveau
des écoles des établissements au niveau
national puisque en fait on sait très
bien que l'état des sanitaires
aujourd'hui est déplorable dans beaucoup
d'écoles bon dans beaucoup
d'établissements scolaires
donc ça n'a pas été fait non plus voilà
il ya toute une organisation à prévoir
et il aurait fallu commencer à la
prévoir dès mai dernier en fait
la situation sanitaire dans le monde à
présent la pandémie de kobe 19 a tué
presque sept cent soixante quinze mille
personnes en amérique latine c'est
l'inquiétude illustration au pérou les
plus démunis ne peuvent plus enterrer
leurs proches dans les cimetières de la
ville faute de moyens mathilde romagnan
un désert de cailloux des croix en bois
avec des noms et des dates des tombes
entouré de pierre
l'aménagement est simple mais ses
habitants n'ont pas le choix les semis
tiers de lima ne peuvent pas accueillir
tous les corps des victimes du coc vide
parce qu'ils n'ont pas de place mais
aussi parce que l'entrée est trop cher
car il faut payer pour avoir une
sépulture à cause du coronavirus si les
nanterre les gens d'en haut qu'un
cimetière autour de kalaba lots ils ne
peuvent les enterrer qu'ici parce que
des gens d'autres endroits viennent ici
ils viennent de come as de vitalité car
aucun cimetière ne les reçoit le seul
qui puisse les recevoir c'est un
cimetière pour lequel il faut payer et
si vous n'avez pas d'argent que fait
donc ce cimetière improvisé a été créée
par les proches des victimes les plus
pauvres du coronavirus dans le district
de qarabagh îlot dans la provence de
lima la capitale selon le ministère de
la santé plus de 26000 personnes sont
mortes du virus au pérou depuis le début
de l'épidémie
ces familles désemparées dénonce aussi
la prise en charge des soins
inégalitaire pour les patients atteints
du coc vide
mes deux fils sont arrivés à cayetano
heredia
c'est là qu'ils sont morts ils m'ont dit
qu'il n'y avait pas de lits de soins
intensifs
ceux ci sont pour les gens qui ont de
l'argent il n'y a pas de salut pour les
pauvres
il n'y en a pas le pérou compte près de
540 mille cas confirmés de coronavirus
et l'épidémie continue de progresser
dimanche les autorités ont enregistré
dix mille nouveaux cas en 24 heures un
record
l' enquête se poursuit à l'île maurice
après la marée noire provoquée par un
bateau japonais l'adjoint et le
capitaine du vraquier wac et chiots ont
été arrêtés hier ils ont été inculpés
pour atteinte à la sécurité de la
navigation d'autres membres de
l'équipage ont été entendus par la
police mauricienne le bâtiment s'était
échoué avec 4000 tonnes d'hydrocarbures
à son bord une partie s'est échappé et a
souillé les côtes mauriciennes notamment
des espaces protégés
de son côté le japon a dépêché
aujourd'hui nouvelle équipe d'experts
sur place pour participer aux efforts de
dépollution
nous évaluerons soigneusement
l'environnement et les dommages causés
par la fuite de pétrole sur le système
écologique côtier en particulier sur les
coraux et les mangroves un organe en
tant qu équipe de secours d'urgence
nous aimerions apporter nos compétences
techniques pour aider à nettoyer la
forêt de mangrove couverte de pétrole
mais c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retourne en 30
minutes pour une nouvelle édition
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
ap
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois